the number one mistake that almost
everyone here is making on Instagram is
they're mailing it in when they do the
copy on their post they're not writing
enough for thoughtfully enough on the
caption on their post they do the video
in the picture they think that's what it
is and on the written word they're just
saying something funny something clever
three words and they're done post if
everybody here started writing three or
four sentences in detail that brought
value to the video that they're posting
they would see enormous growth from
their Baseline overnight maybe for you
you're not good on video but you can
take a picture of your product or your
service or your industry and then write
three paragraphs on your Instagram post
and that's how you grow there's a
hundred different ways to win this game
the only way to guarantee that you don't
win is by doing nothing about it